sweat plays a huge role in the world of
dune the novel takes place mostly on the
planet arrakis a dangerously hot planet
where inhabitants must recycle their own
sweat to survive but despite sweat's
life-saving role the film adaptation
rarely shows anybody sweating at all and
when it does show sweat it's
inconsistent of course this is probably
not an accident or an oversight it's an
intentional choice by the filmmakers and
this use of sweat in dune not only shows
the importance of sweat in movies as a
whole but it also reveals why a movie
like dune needed more of it so let's
take a look at some of our favorite
movie characters and ask them a question
why are you so sweaty
[Music]
at first glance sweat doesn't carry the
same emotional weight as more direct
emotional cues like seeing blood or
watching someone cry sweat doesn't
signify death or sadness it's a
seemingly straightforward biological
response to heat or stress but like
blood and tears sweat in movies is
carefully choreographed the sweat we see
in movies is often controlled not by the
actor's sweat glands but by the makeup
department it's not like sylvester
stallone can maintain that insane level
of sweat for an entire day of shooting
between takes makeup artist leonard
engelman sprayed him down with a water
glycerin mixture that mimics the
viscosity of sweat making stallone look
hard at work thanks to movie magic
actors who look sweaty and exhausted on
screen could actually feel quite
comfortable on set but that's not always
the case makeup artists also have to
deal with the opposite keeping
uncomfortable sweaty actors looking dry
whether it's thick costumes makeup
prosthetics or powerful lighting
equipment film sets tend to run on the
sweaty side like when the actors in it's
a wonderful life had to wear winter
coats while filming on a sound stage in
90 degree weather the dojo scene in the
matrix required intense lights so the
camera could capture slow motion which
meant the makeup team had to pat down
the actors in between takes the reason
to remove sweat is obvious for it's a
wonderful life it would look strange for
actors to look hot in the winter but in
the matrix the lack of sweat does more
by explaining the world of the matrix
morpheus shouldn't sweat in the dojo
because he knows how to bend the laws of
physics in the matrix and since neo
hasn't learned that yet he still sweats
so when we do see morpheus sweat during
his interrogation we can tell he's no
longer in control so sweat can work as a
sort of visual shorthand showing who's
under pressure and who isn't don't say
it don't you say left come on and this
phenomenon reveals what makes sweat so
important in movies sweat isn't just a
biological response to heat it's also a
biological response to stress something
wrong
patrick
you're sweating so directors use sweat
in this way to give us insight into
certain characters even within the same
exact room the emotional characters can
sweat a lot while the cool analytical
ones don't sweat at all don't you ever
sweat
no i don't you may not notice it
consciously but our lizard brains
definitely associate sweat with stress
remember the opening shot of the first
teaser trailer for the force awakens
have you felt it
the narration is right you can feel it
sweat is crucial to this moment because
it signals that finn is in the middle of
a chase and it adds to the mystery of
what's off screen and where all the
sounds are coming from compare that to
paul in dune who looks like he's just
getting started
the movie dune shows just how much
creative liberty makeup departments have
when it comes to sweat many characters
don't sweat at all or they sweat
inconsistently take this scene where one
character sweats but paul is bone dry
i'm sure most people watching the movie
didn't notice this inconsistency but
this choice does have an emotional
effect on the viewer by making paul the
dry one in this scene he feels more calm
royal and unaffected by the toxic
environment filmmakers often reserve
sweat for those actively working which
has the added effect of separating the
pampered elite from the ones performing
the labor in this way sweat can
emphasize class divides showing who
suffers and who gets to stay dry in blue
collar jerry starts off as a sweaty auto
worker but by the end he is transformed
into a white collar worker with a clean
brow so sweat can accomplish much more
than just showing the temperature and
it's a wonderful life james stewart's
character actually sweats a lot even
during a winter snowstorm stewart
probably looked like that because the
set was nearly 100 degrees but it
doesn't feel unrealistic on the contrary
by having him sweat in the middle of
winter the audience feels his emotional
anguish that much more some filmmakers
go one step further and make their
characters sweatier than humanly
possible this exaggeration usually leads
to comedy but it can also work in
dramatic movies in raging bull the
makeup team had to cover robert de niro
in vaseline so that sweat would fly off
his face when he moved and that effect
combined with the animal sound effects
and disorienting camera work creates a
boxing ring full of violence and chaos
but perhaps the greatest practitioner of
sweaty characters comes from the
director sergio leone take the nine
minute opening credits in his spaghetti
western once upon a time in the west
which consists of three silent
gunslingers sitting around waiting for
the train a scene so uneventful should
feel incredibly boring so how did sergio
leone make a bunch of people doing
nothing feel so electric part of the
magic comes from the characters menacing
introductions and the initial mystery of
why they appeared at the station but i
think the true reason why leone could
hold onto these characters for so long
is simply because they're also irritated
one has water drip on his head one
spends way too long dealing with a fly
and the other sits around looking bored
all while a windmill creaks in the
background not much happens physically
but a lot happens emotionally they
aren't moving but they are sweating so
you can feel their internal intensity
long before they fire their guns when
you really think about it the majority
of a shootout in a western movie is just
two guys staring each other down the
characters aren't actually doing
anything but we can feel the stakes
beneath that motionless surface in these
moments each beat of sweat matters as
much as the sound design or the camera
or the film score because sweat betrays
the true intensity within the stillness
but the characters in sergio leone films
tend to sweat not just during climactic
moments but throughout the entire movie
sweat creates a lingering reminder of
the constant uncomfortable heap and of
the never-ending harshness of their
world other movies like dog day
afternoon and do the right thing
similarly use constant sweat to show
pent-up tension in their respective
brooklyn neighborhoods but dune chooses
not to go this route paul doesn't sweat
when it's hot he only sweats when he's
undergoing mental anguish like during
the pain test scene or when he
hallucinates his sweating inside the
tent gives the scene a claustrophobic
feel and the way his sweat combines with
his tears creates an emotional cocktail
that really sells the moment so the dune
makeup department reserves sweat for the
internal climactic moments but that
choice comes at the expense of not
really getting a sense for the external
heat of the planet and i think that's a
shame because going the route of the
spaghetti western would have given the
viewer a constant reminder of the
inhospitable nature of the planet
arrakis
well when i came home from school my
head started to get really hot
at the end of the day sweat is one of
the great human equalizers everybody
does it and it's not something a person
has control over so when the makeup
department makes a decision on sweat
they're essentially choosing to add or
remove humanity from a character or from
a setting so when dune doesn't use sweat
often it subtly makes house atreides
feel invincible when in reality the
house had trouble adjusting to the harsh
environment of arrakis we don't get to
feel that tension as strongly with such
dry looking characters in a world where
sweat literally keeps you alive i think
the absence of sweat drains some life
from the story and in a cinematic
landscape increasingly propped up by cgi
and polished big budget experiences
there's more need than ever for the
delightfully human imperfection that is
sweat because we don't go to the movies
just to see an external conflict we also
go to see an internal one so the next
time you watch a great movie remember
that it took three things to make it
blood
[Music]
as always thank you to my patreon
supporters who got to see the video
early and some even got to help out with
the script thanks for watching